[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen tennis und fußball hat gleich
norbert könig für sich ganz genau ich
will und wir beginnen mit der deutschen
politik unsere wichtigsten themen heute
kritik nach ampel sondierungen
unternehmer und umweltschützer bemängeln
die pläne für die wahlschlappe der union
übernimmt cdu-chef laschet die alleinige
verantwortung
trauer nach messerattentat die britische
polizei stuft den mord an einem
abgeordneten als terrorakt ein
kein wasser kaum etwas zu essen
dramatische dürren verschärfen die
situation in ärmeren ländern
wie sollen die vorhaben einer möglichen
ampelkoalition finanziert werden das ist
einer der größten kritikpunkte an den
sondierungsergebnisse von spd grünen und
fdp schauen wir noch mal auf die
wichtigsten punkte auf die sich die drei
parteien geeinigt haben von einem geben
und nehmen sprechen die sonn ihrer für
jeden ist etwas dabei der gesetzliche
mindestlohn soll auf zwölf euro steigen
ein kernanliegen der spd auch die fdp
hat einiges durchsetzen können
steuererhöhungen sind vom tisch und die
grünen betonen dass umfangreiche klima
sofortprogramm die verhandler und
verhandlerin loben ihre pläne aber
kritik gibt es von vielen seiten nicole
diekmann
die ampel seit gestern um einen
entscheidenden schritt wahrscheinlicher
spd grüne und fdp vereint hinter einem
12 seitigen papier und in großer
euphorie die überträgt sich aber nicht
auf alle umweltschützern etwa gehen die
ideen längst nicht weit genug
es ist eine fünf für mich auf einer
skala von 1 bis 10 die ich jetzt sehe
ich glaube es sind chancen in dem papier
aber es ist jetzt deutlich mehr zu tun
im bereich mobilität zu wende im bereich
landwirtschaft und naturschutz das
urteil der arbeitgeberverbände
vernichtend der im papier geplante
mindestlohn von 12 euro sei
brandgefährlich
eine derartige mindestlohn grenze würde
eine enorme lohnspirale nach oben
erzeugen und somit den arbeitsmarkt für
geringqualifizierte unheimlich
erschweren das ist genauso falsch wie
damals das gezieltere falsch war als den
mindestlohn eingeführt haben wir kennen
die momente sondern menschen brauchen
einen lohn von dem sie halbwegs gut
leben können und wo sie nicht am ende
des monats noch über grundsicherung über
hartz iv aufstocken wollen die linke
skeptisch kostspielige vorhaben aber
keine steuererhöhungen für große
einkommen das passe nicht zusammen wenn
man wirklich ein investitions jahrzehnt
will dann muss das untersetzt werden ich
frage mich wie soll das alles finanziert
werden beim deutschlandtag der jungen
union hingegen respekt von armin laschet
dem sehr wahrscheinlich gescheiterten
kanzlerkandidaten von cdu und csu
das papier was da vorgelegt wurde ist
in ordnung
wir hätten manches wir auch mitmachen
können machtwechsel im kanzleramt die
ampel sondern sind einen schritt weiter
schon kommende woche könnten sie
koalitionsverhandlung sein
während eine ampelkoalition immer
konkretere züge annimmt rückt eine
jamaika-koalition in immer weitere ferne
und so beschäftigen sich cdu/csu gerade
vor allem mit sich selbst beim treffen
der jungen union übernahm cdu-chef
lasche die alleinige verantwortung für
das historisch schlechte abschneiden bei
der bundestagswahl
weniger schauer mit den einzelheiten aus
münster
armin laschet ist gekommen um über seine
niederlage und die der union zu reden
das kanzleramt ist geschichte und die
verantwortung für dieses ergebnis die
trage ich als vorsitzender und als
kanzlerkandidat er erntet mit seiner
selbstkritik mehr respekt als kritik ich
war von anfang an nicht für sie als
parteivorsitzenden und jetzt haben sie
gezeigt ich finde das kurz ehrlichkeit
dazu das zu sagen aber jetzt chapeau für
diese ehrlichkeit armin laschet rechnet
auch mit markus söder ab den er nicht
beim namen nennt man vor ort entschieden
hat die oder der ist unser kandidat und
danach sagen die anderen die nicht
gewählt worden sind ja aber bier hat
trotzdem den besseren wenn man so in
wahlen geht gewinnt man nicht zum
aufeinandertreffen kommt es nicht söder
hatte der lotto erst zu dann abgesagt
besuchte am vormittag lieber die csu in
oberfranken
der streit so laschet fehlende
strategien keine inhalte es sind die
beiden generalsekretäre die scharf für
die wahlniederlage kritisiert werden und
unsere politische beliebigkeit
manifestiert sich hier ich möchte die
werte verantwortlich und wie kann das
verhindert werden dass es nie wieder
passiert dann wer bei wird nach laschet
den kurs der cdu bestimmen junge besen
kehren gut
aber die alte bürste kennt die ecken es
ist jetzt mal die generation nach merkel
die jetzt mal in verantwortung muss
ambitionen gibt es also bislang alle
männlich aus nordrhein-westfalen
offizielle kandidaturen gibt es noch
nicht
und das treffen der jungen union hat
mathis feldhoff für uns beobachtet
gerade es ist für heute zu ende gegangen
mattes die union will sich also erneuern
wie genau er
ist eine gute frage weil die union
gerade feststellt dass dieses
wahlergebnis gnadenlos offen legt dass
diese partei eigentlich momentan gar
nicht weiß wofür sie noch steht die
junge union hat heute ihren beiden
mutterparteien doch bittere wahrheiten
ins stammbuch geschrieben unter anderem
dass sie die nase voll davon haben dass
diese beiden parteivorsitzenden sich
gegenseitig so angehen diese deutschland
tage sind ja immer so was wie ein
schaulaufen und gerade jetzt wo die cdu
einen neuen parteivorsitzenden sucht
jens spahn und auch friedrich merz sind
ja immer die lieblinge der jungen union
gewesen um überraschender ist es dass
sie beide heute und gestern einen eher
mageren applaus bekommen haben die
herzen der jungen union fliegen längst
anderen zu etwa dem
cdu-wirtschaftspolitiker rasten carsten
linnemann dass markus söder heute sich
nicht der diskussion gestellt hat und
diese parteiveranstaltungen hier merkt
man muss sagen geschwänzt hat hat einen
schalen beigeschmack bei der jungen
union hinterlassen und lässt nichts
gutes hoffen für die weiteren debatten
in der union danke für diese
einschätzung mathis feldhoff
bundeskanzlerin merkel hält sich aus den
diskussionen ihrer partei dagegen heraus
und es stattdessen auf eine art
abschiedstour heute beim türkischen
präsidenten erdogan in istanbul
bei dem gespräch war merkel dafür das
flüchtlings abkommen zwischen der eu und
der türkei fortzuführen mit wolf hat
über die wohl letzte türkei reise
merkels als bundeskanzlerin
die stimmung wirkte er gelöst als die
kanzlerin mit dem türkischen präsidenten
vor die kameras trat sichtlich bemüht
bei ihrem wohl letzten besuch die
positiven seiten im verhältnis zu einem
schwierigen nato partner hervorzuheben
wir merken dass wir geostrategisch eben
sehr voneinander abhängen ob wir gleich
agieren oder nicht das wird jetzt mit
der frage der taliban eine rolle spielen
das spielt mit der frage der flüchtlinge
eine rolle sie wollte sich beim eu
gipfel nächste woche in brüssel dafür
einsetzen dass die türkei über die
bewilligten 6 milliarden euro hinaus
weitere eu-hilfen für die versorgung der
flüchtlinge erhalten lobte merkel dafür
dass sie immer nach einer lösung gesucht
habe auch bei schwierigen problemen wie
der flüchtlingsfrage
es gibt für die türkei viele
schwierigkeiten auf dem weg zur
eu-mitgliedschaft trotzdem hat sich frau
merkel stets für uns eingesetzt dafür
danken wir ihr und wir werden das in
guter erinnerung behalten
es gebe aber weiter erhebliche
schwierigkeiten insbesondere bei
rechtsstaatlichkeit und meinungsfreiheit
so die kanzlerin mehrere dutzend
deutsche staatsbürger sind derzeit in
der türkei unter fadenscheinigen terror
vorwürfen inhaftiert wir haben hier noch
eine menge schwierigkeiten zu überwinden
aber immer wieder bin ich der
überzeugung dass es nur durch gespräche
gelingen kann und durch kontakte
gelingen kann auch die unterschiedlichen
fragen seien des menschenrechte seines
die zypern-frage oder anderes zu
überwinden manches so merkel dauere sehr
lange 16 jahre hätten dafür nicht
ausgereicht
in großbritannien ist nach dem tödlichen
attentat gestern auf den tory
abgeordnete names eine debatte entbrannt
über die sicherheit von politikerinnen
die polizei geht von einem terrorakt aus
premierminister johnson besuchte heute
den tatort des messerangriffs im
englischen küstenort li und sie diana
zimmermann berichtet
gemeinsam legten premier und
oppositionsführer blumen nieder vor dem
gebäude in dem david haines gestern
ermordet wurde kollegen aller parteien
äußerten sich bestürzt und besorgt
er wurde ermordet während er den job
ausübte den er liebte den bürgern als
gewählter abgeordneter zu dienen solche
akte sind absolut falsch und wir können
nicht zulassen dass das dem
funktionieren unserer demokratie im weg
steht der 69 jährige konservative
dragset anhänger und leidenschaftliche
tierschützer war während seiner
wöchentlichen sprechstunden erstochen
worden die polizei ermittelt auch in
richtung einer islamistisch
extremistischen motivation ein 25
jähriger brite vermutlich somalischer
herkunft wurde noch am tatort
festgenommen
es ist das zweite mal in fünf jahren
dass ein aktiver britischer
parlamentarier opfer einer gewalttat
wird wenige tage vor dem brett
referendum war die labour-politikerin jo
kox von einem rechtsradikalen ermordet
worden ihre schwester ist nun selbst
abgeordnete
young koche ich versuche menschen zu
helfen und gutes zu bewirken es ist
wichtig dass wir gute leute in diese
jobs bekommen aber das ist das risiko
dass wir dafür eingehen müssen
wie viele andere klagte auch david
haines darüber dass er zunehmend
angefeindet wurde zum schutz der
politiker wird nun überlegt die in der
britischen demokratie üblichen
bürgersprechstunden solange online
abzuhalten bis neue sicherheitsmaßnahmen
in kraft treten
[Musik]
eine woche ist es her dass mitglieder
der rechtsextremen partei vor 10 uhr war
ein gewerkschafts sitz in rom
angegriffen haben als reaktion darauf
demonstrierten heute zehntausende in der
italienischen hauptstadt gegen
faschismus mit fahnen und bannern
forderten gewerkschaft anhänger innen
und verschiedene linke gruppen unter
anderem die auflösung der partei
blicken wir auf den heutigen
welternährungstag erinnert daran dass
noch immer hunderte millionen menschen
hunger wegen kriegen der pandemie oder
den folgen der klimakrise manche
menschen sind auf jeden tropfen wasser
auf jede noch so kleine mahlzeit
angewiesen in kenia verschärft eine
dramatische dürre die lage auswahl
berichtet susann von
17 wasserstellen gab es früher in way
you im osten kenias jetzt noch eine
letzte lebensader für vieh und mensch
hunderte tiere sammeln sich um die rinde
dazwischen männer und frauen die ihre
kanister fühlen ab und zu stellt die
regierung einen tank auf zum waschen
essen kochen trinken das wasser eine
braune brühe
wenn man es einmal probiert hat weiß man
dass es viel zu salzig ist wie das kein
mensch ist schlucken kann aber da sie
nichts haben sind die kinder gezwungen
es zu trinken
gallo ist der letzte ehrenamtliche
helfer der im krankenhaus von mario
geblieben ist mütter kommen mit ihren
kindern sie haben magen und
darmerkrankungen sind massiv unter
ernährt
ich habe vier kinder und für sie sehen
gibt es kein essen ich fürchte dass uns
die schlimmsten zeiten noch bevorstehen
es ist diese schreckliche dürre
seit über einem jahr hat es nicht
geregnet die trockenheit wird anhalten
sagen experten die menschen müssten sich
umstellen
dazu gehört auch die veränderung der
lebensgrundlagen auf die diese
gemeinschaften angewiesen sind um sie
resistenter zu machen gegen die dürre
krise
90 kilometer entfernt von way you sure
to end bauern beim anbau von
süßkartoffeln sie brauchen viel weniger
wasser sind robuster und vor allem
nährstoffreich das projekt ist schon
jetzt ein erfolg über 300 familien
können von der ernte leben und hoffen
trotz der dürre auf eine bessere zukunft
wenn sie den menschen helfen wollen
können sie das beim aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe tun das spendenkonto
hat die bahn de 65 104 106 100 104 106
100 stichwort zdf hunger in afrika
weitere informationen finden sie unter
spenden punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 8 190
gerade der pandemie haben wieder mehr
menschen bücher gelesen einfach und
günstig geht das über online
bibliotheken nachteil man kriegt dort
nur selten neuerscheinungen
das wird die politik jetzt ändern
autorinnen und verlage sehen dadurch
allerdings ihre existenzgrundlage
gefährdet und starteten heute eine
initiative gegen die pläne isabel de la
vega berichtet
schreiben davon leben autoren wie juli
zeh und fühlen sich nun in ihrer
existenz bedroht in einer kampagne
wehren sich zäh und 180 weitere autoren
gegen neue regeln bei der ausleihe von
ebooks schreiben sei nicht umsonst wir
versuchen zu verhindern dass auf dem
buchmarkt was ähnliches passiert wie auf
dem musikmarkt nämlich dadurch durch
dass die nutzer sich daran gewöhnen
kulturelle produkte kostenlos aus dem
internet runterzuladen am ende für die
urheber und urheberin nichts mehr
übrigbleibt worauf sie ihre existenz
stützen können öffentliche bibliotheken
bieten ihren mitgliedern ebooks über das
portal online an online boomt und weil
die verlage dabei nicht so viel
verdienen wie ein verkauften e-books
oder gedruckten büchern geben sie ihre
bestseller meist monate später für die
onleihe frei das wollen die bibliotheken
ändern
wir fordern eine gesetzliche regelung
für den fall für den verleih für ebooks
dass die verlage verpflichtet werden mit
erscheinen eines ebooks den bibliotheken
dieses e-book anzubieten
eine entsprechende gesetzesinitiative
liegt bereits im bundesrat die verleger
reagieren empört wann neuerscheinungen
in die online kommen wollen sie weiter
selbst entscheiden
bibliotheken werden von steuergeldern
bezahlt die erlöse für die verlage sind
entsprechend niedrig und deshalb braucht
der verlag mit seinen autorinnen und
autoren die freiheit hier zu entscheiden
in welchem maße man in diesem bereich
tätig ist und in welchem auch nicht auch
auf der frankfurter buchmesse kommende
woche wird der streit um die ebook
ausleihe ein wichtiges thema sein
so kann es für alexanders wäre es ist ja
dass turnieren in den holster ende
norbert das besonders ärgerlich nach
zwei vergebenen mit der hohe favorit
alexander schwere verliert in drei
sätzen gegen den us amerikaner taylor
fritz der in der setzliste 28 plätze
hinter ihm steht sein zweiter nicht
verwandelt damit sparen lässt das spiel
kippen doppelfehler eine 5 2-führung im
dritten satz aus den händen gegeben
schweres spiel gerät in schieflage im
gleichen maße steigert sich taylor fritz
die nummer 39 der welt der us amerikaner
erzwingt den tie break
heute war irgendwie nicht mein tag die
stand kurz vor dem sieg aber mein spiel
hatte nicht das gewohnte niveau
fritz schien schon geschlagen gewinnt
dann den tie-break mit 7 zu 3 vielleicht
hat es wäre schon zu sehr an die
möglichen turniersieg gedacht
tolles comeback für oerlinghausen der
norweger trifft nach seiner
verletzungspause zweimal für dortmund
und befördert den bvb vorläufig an die
bundesliga-spitze drei zu eins gewinnt
die borussia gegen mainz 05 vor 64.000
zuschauern
freiburgs erstes spiel im neuen stadion
11 16 6 punkte für berlin die hertha
gewinnt 2 zu 1 in frankfurt union 2 zu 0
gegen den vfl wolfsburg und das
kellerduell verliert wird daheim gegen
bochum mit 0 zu 1 am abend noch
mönchengladbach gegen stuttgart gestern
hoffenheim köln 50 morgen das
gipfeltreffen leverkusen gegen die
bayern sowie augsburg bielefeld
dortmund ist für mindestens 24 stunden
tabellenführer der sieger im duell
bayern gegen bayern würde vorbeiziehen
dahinter ungeschlagene freiburger nur
eine niederlage bisher für union
wolfsburg jetzt schon drei mal ohne
punkte
mainz in der unteren hälfte angekommen
härter klettert auf 12 aufsteiger bochum
verlässt die abstiegszone der andere
aufsteiger greuther fürth mit nur einem
punkt und tor differenz - 15
das abendspiel gladbach vfb ausführlich
im aktuellen sportstudio um fünf nach
elf zu gast ist kölns trainer steffen
baumgart nach dem 0 zu 5 in hoffenheim
fünf zu null gewinnt jürgen klopp mit
dem fc liverpool beim fc watford und hat
damit in der premier league den
spitzenreiter chelsea mit kollege thomas
tuchel zumindest vorläufig überholt
jürgen klopp und der fc liverpool auch
nach acht spieltagen ungeschlagen man
eröffnet das schützenfest mit seinem 100
premier league treffer in der neunten
minute in der 37 ist es für mio der
gegenüber dem überforderten team von
wort ford auf 2 0 erhöht überragender
mann des spiels und von klopp als
derzeit weltbester profi gefeiert
musallam der zum 4 zu 0 trifft in der
nachspielzeit sorgt für mini mit seinem
dritten treffer für den 5 0-endstand
chelsea mit teammanager tuchel kann
heute abend die tabellenspitze
zurückerobert die
hat meine wetter kollegin katja hornuf
die vorhersage für morgen so schön
zusammengefasst ruhiges zu nebel
neigendes herbstwetter und die kleinen
feinheiten dazu hat sie gleich für sie
claus kleber größte um 22.50 zum heute
journal und wir wünschen ihnen noch
einen schönen samstagabend
[Musik]
guten abend vielleicht haben sie heute
ähnliches gesehen wie volkmar brockhaus
im arnsberger wald in
nordrhein-westfalen buntes herbstlaub
und dahinter blauer himmel hin und
wieder musste sich erstmal nebel oder
dunst oder hochnebel auflösen wie zb am
oberrhein an der mosel oder auch am
bodensee wenn der nebel cvat anlagen die
temperaturen kaum bei zehn grad mit
strahlendem sonnenschein ging es auf 15
grad drauf richtung norddeutschland
waren die wolken dichter und brachten
aber etwas regen mit und das bleibt
jetzt auch in der nacht so in der mitte
und im süden breiten sich wieder
nebelfelder aus und da sinken die
temperaturen meist auf plus 4 bis minus
1 grad örtlich droht bodenfrost unter
den dichteren wolken im norden bleibt es
bei zehn bis fünf grad milder morgen die
idee temperaturen ganz ähnlich wie heute
zwischen 11 grad auf rügen und 16 grad
am alpenrand und auch morgen muss ich
erstmal nebel und dunst auflösen das
klappt wahrscheinlich nicht mehr ganz so
gut wie heute richtung norddeutschland
sind die wolken dichter und an den
küsten fällt noch etwas regen
die neue woche wird erst milder und dann
wilder montag ändert sich wenig am
dienstag ziehen schon regenwolken über
uns hinweg und spätestens mittwoch
nachmittag oder in der nacht zu
donnerstag droht dann der erste
herbststurm von der nordsee schönes
wochenende